1 2 3 vive les enfants
et vive la famille
opération un manifestant un ballon à La
Verrière ce samedi une vingtaine d'ondes
petits mariages pour tous réunis à
l'appel du collectif La Verrière pour la
famille alors c'est pas un mouvement
politique on est non partisan c'est un
mouvement qui regroupe des verrues
sur les conséquences de la loi les
conséquences qui sont dramatiques pour
les enfants pour les familles avec le
risque de la PMA procréation
médicalement assistée la GP1 les mers
porteuses on n'est pas vraiment contre
le mariage homosexuel mais ce qui
accompagne tout simplement cette loi à
la PMA tout ça aujourd'hui en France par
exemple des lois sur les OGM on les a
recalés en disant on n'a pas assez le
recul dessus et là pour la PMA on nous
l'a fait passer de force nous sommes
mobilisés pour défendre effectivement le
la famille la famille et les droits de
l'enfant d'avoir un père et une mère
reconnu qu'ils aient effectivement leurs
racines connues reconnues et non pas
effectivement une constitution d'une
famille qui n'en serait plus une
ce rassemblement d'une demi-heure était
le préambule de la manifestation
parisienne du lendemain contre le
mariage pour tous l'occasion de répéter
leur slogan
on veut du boulot pas du mariage homo
les anti mariages pour tous précises
qu'ils ne lâcheront rien pour reprendre
leur terme et pense même un recours
constitutionnel si la loi est votée
solennellement mardi à l'Assemblée
nationale